це будівля колишнього кінотеатру в
Кишиневі тут знаходиться один із центрів
розміщення біженців з Україною який
скоро реорганізують після початку
повномасштабної війни тут розгорнули
тимчасовий притулок для українців
розрахований на 230 осіб але зараз тут
лише 24 людини серед них і 64-річна
Наталія Петренко з Одеси приїхала 5
ноября 22 года 5 листопада 2022 року
тому що в нашому районі почався сильний
обстріл обстріляли нафтобазу обстріляли
дві військові частини і це було вже все
край я це вже було все уже потолок у
розпорядженні українських біженців
психолог юрист та медик тут є всі Вигоди
триразове харчування тільки ось обідають
люди в приміщенні де колись був
караоке-бар про це свідчить майже повна
відсутність вікон сцена та написи на
стінах ну або ось поверхом вище барна
стійка навколо якої встановили ліжка
тепер людям обіцяють надати найкращої
умови Наталія Петренко каже що
невибаглива аби дах над головою був
повертатися до рідної Одеси вона поки що
боїться Я
человек Я дуже хвора людина у мене
розбили будинок А я Наступного дня
поїхала сюди бо нервовий стрес був на
квартиру грошей немає Я краще в
гуртожитку поживу може такі додому поїду
я б вже поїхала Та от Сьогодні знову
обіцяли обстрілювати нашу Одесу А я в
такому районі живу що в нас спорт внизу
нафтобаза воно так розміщене що все
летить дуже страшно що воно там прямо Ну
очень страшно А ця жінка виховує сина
самотужки майже рік тому вони приїхали
до Молдови з Одеської області хлопець
нещодавно вступив до вишу в Кишиневі і
незабаром переїде в гуртожиток а його
мама перебереться до іншого центру для
біженців
з ногами у мене проблеми з ногами
хвороба потрібно влаштуватися на роботу
подивимося
даже устроилась на роботу не хватало але
якби навіть влаштувалася на роботу не
вистачало фінансів мені допомагати В
інституті мамі винаймати квартиру
оплачувати комунальні одяг продукти А ми
у двох тільки
у нас допомоги ніякої немає тата немає
Тяжко буде продовжити роботу цей центр
не може через скорочення кількості
жителів утримання будівлі обходиться
надто
дорогоці з тобою
ви можете уявити собі скільки коштує
утримання такого триповерхового центру
потрібно щоб весь час хоч десь горіло
світло у коридорі у дворі
електроенергії витрачається дуже багато
а взимку з огляду на те що в деяких
кімнатах 6-7 батарей на опалення йдуть
десятки тисяч румунських леїв
тут ще й небезпечно до відкриття
притулку будинок кілька років був
порожнім сліди цього добре видно у
підвалі гори сміття та оголені дроти це
відео зняла для нас координаторка
установи тим Хто захоче переїхати на
квартиру держава за підтримки
закордонних партнерів оплачуватиме житло
але воно не повинно бути дорожчим за 275
євро кажуть у міністерстві праці та
соцзахисту Молдови Олена шапорова мати
трьох дітей одна з перших хто отримав
допомогу за цією програмою жінка
приїхала до Кишинева з Одеси у перший
день повномасштабної війни Діти дуже
злякалися розповідає Олена У центрі
облаштованому у Старому кінотеатрі вони
прожили півтора року але Настав час
перегорнути сторінку каже Вона квартиру
дуже хороша домашня затишна нам там
добре буде
так же паралельно так само разом з цією
пропозицією надійшла пропозиція
працювати
я працюватиму в Момо у цій компанії я
буду волонтеркою нагадуватиму нашому
українським жінкам з дітьми і без дітей
про календар щеплень щоб вони всі
щеплення робили вчасно а тому що є
календарь прививок чтобы они не
здобували делать все прививки воврем зі
140 центрів відкритих на початку
повномасштабної війни в Україні у
Молдові зараз працюють лише 52 третина з
них заповнені лише частково А чи ж
доуміт часу та Куман чи Андріє і усі дві
з половиною тисячі осіб які перебувають
у центрах будуть проконсультовані з
кожним поговорять окремо і ті Хто захоче
стати частиною цієї програми матимуть
змогу скористатися коштами ті Хто захоче
залишитися в центрах залишаться повторю
ми нікого не виганяємо не змушуємо
їм пост у міністер кажуть що Це робиться
для того щоб допомогти українцям
інтегруватися у суспільство
через те що ми дуже довго тримали їх у
цих центрах у них з'явилася залежність
вони звикли до цих умов вони забезпечені
житлом харчуванням допомогою мають
практично готельні умови плюс вони
одержують фінансову допомогу від донорів
так у випадку людей з обмеженими
можливостями це можна зрозуміти але
багато з них працездатного віку вони
можуть повинні інтегруватися у
суспільство влаштуватися на роботу та
бути корисними за словами чиновника
Влада за підтримки закордонних партнерів
намагатиметься продовжити програму
підтримки українців які винаймають житло
крім того обіцяють зворотний зв'язок та
допомогу у працевлаштуванні Якщо
говорити про загальну цифру то за
підрахунками фахівців на території
Молдови залишаються близько 80 тисяч
біженців з України вони щомісяця
отримують матеріальну допомогу у розмірі
110 євро на кожного члена сім'ї допомогу
надає агентство ООН у справах біженців
крім того допомогу отримує сторона що
приймає їх